When it comes to action movies, 2021 has
been going pretty well so far. Out of all
those theatrical releases and streaming debuts,
however, it's hard to know which are the cream
of the crop. Have no fear, though — these
are the best action movies of 2021 so far.
In March 2021, after much demand from the
franchise's fans, DC and Warner Bros. released
director Zack Snyder's original vision for
the Justice League's first live-action film.
Following the 2017 release of Joss Whedon's
much-derided Franken-movie, no one knew quite
what to expect from this new take on Snyder's
original vision. But the end results are strong,
featuring more fleshed out story arcs for each
member of the team and a villain with more
relatable motivations. But Zack Snyder's Justice
League truly delivers with its action scenes.
To die-hard Snyder fans, the director's talent
for action will come as no surprise. For anybody
who hadn't yet experienced his particular brand
of artfully framed, gleefully ridiculous action,
however, Justice League is a superb
demonstration of what he does best.
The setup for Godzilla vs. Kong is simple:
Godzilla attacks humanity unprovoked,
so the humans call upon Kong to lead them
to a source of energy that can defeat him.
During the journey, the Terror of Tokyo
crosses paths with the eighth wonder of
the world — and they throw down to see
who gets to be king of the monsters.
While the movie received mixed reviews on
release, critics have largely praised its
Kong on Zilla action. Director Adam Wingard's
previous movies, You're Next and The Guest,
married a number of genres with some
seriously effective action scenes.
And Wingard's greatest success in
Godzilla vs. Kong is his keen ability
to plot out those fight scenes and make every
punch, bite, and nuclear breath blast count.
And sure, the critics have taken issue with
Godzilla vs. Kong's plotting and character
development, but that's not really the point
of this movie, is it? As a wise man once said:
"Let them fight."
Watching an action movie can sometimes
feel like visiting a familiar diner.
You know the menu, you know what you
like, and you know what not to order.
So when a movie like Nobody comes along, any
fan of the genre knows they're in for a very
specific viewing experience. Produced by one
half of the John Wick brain trust, David Leitch,
and starring funny man Bob Odenkirk, Nobody
nonetheless proved to be certifiably awesome.
This movie brings such relish
to what it is attempting,
from the performances to the fight
choreography to the plot itself,
that it easily stands out in the long line of
action-thriller franchises that came before it.
Most of that success is due to Odenkirk himself
— who, in a stroke of genius, plays Hutch Mansell
like a recovering addict; one who has gleefully
broken a long, cold-turkey run of non-violence.
Throw in a wonderful supporting cast and
some deft direction from Ilya Naishuller,
and you've got one of those rare movies that
truly transcends the tried-and-tested formula.
World War 2 is having a bit of a genre moment
right now, and movies blending extreme war
violence with sci-fi/horror action have become
a cottage industry — think 2018's Overlord or
The Outpost franchise. What makes Shadow
in the Cloud unique to this niche category,
however, is its perspective and
focus on the women in the war effort.
Shadow tells the story of Chloe Grace Moretz's
Flight Officer Maude Garret, and the secret
mission that has her hitching a ride on a B-52
bomber in the midst of Japanese occupied airspace.
The first half of the movie basically confines
Moretz to the bottom turret of the plane.
Her isolation is in one of the worst places to be
in an aircraft — outside and underneath it. Pair
that with the sexist verbal abuse she receives
from the male crew over the radio, and the movie
builds a highly specific brand of suspense not
often seen on the silver screen. But things
really get crazy when spoiler-heavy details
reveal themselves, allowing the movie to dive
into some B-movie action that wouldn't feel out
of place in an empty movie theater in the 1980s.
If you haven't already, give this one a shot —
it's as silly as anything and well worth a watch.
The Fast and the Furious movies aren't about
car chases. They aren't about wild stunts,
either, or muscled-up dudes punching each
other. Okay, so maybe they're about those
things a little — but at the end of the
day, this franchise is all about one thing:
"I don't have friends. I got family."
That's especially true in F9, in
which everybody's favorite street
racer Dominic Toretto butts heads with
his estranged brother, Jakob. Obviously,
the result is a whole bunch of car chases, wild
stunts, and muscled-up dudes punching each other.
Luckily, F9 is also one of the best installments
in a truly wild and incredible franchise.
It hails the return of Justin Lin, the director
who reinvigorated the series with Tokyo Drift
and created a new direction
for the franchise with parts 4,
5, and 6. Here, the filmmaker expertly
blends the melodrama with the spectacle,
giving long-time fans of the franchise everything
they want and more. If you're looking for a fun,
fast-paced, and heartfelt time at the movies,
F9 is the perfect action film for you.
Cinematically speaking, 2021 has been a fantastic
year for Zack Snyder. In addition to
wowing critics and fans alike with his
unadulterated take on Justice League, the man gave
Dave Bautista a machine gun, sent him to Sin City,
and had him shoot down a whole bunch of
zombies. Talk about peak action cinema.
Army of the Dead takes place in a world where a
zombie uprising has been confined to Las Vegas.
The undead shuffle past slot machines, poker
tables... and a vault filled with $200 million.
And so zombie-killing veteran
Scott Ward is hired to assemble
a team of mercenaries to make their
way into Vegas and retrieve the cash.
If they succeed? It's the ultimate
jackpot. If not? Well, you know...
Things get complicated when it turns out the
government plans on nuking Vegas off the face of
the Earth. Things get even more complicated when
Scott's estranged daughter tags along. And things
get even more complicated when the zombies reveal
themselves to be far more than your ordinary
ghouls. Army of the Dead: it's silly, it's loud,
it's gory. What more could you possibly want?
It took way too long for Natasha Romanoff to get
her own movie — but now that Black Widow is here,
it turns out the final result was definitely
worth the wait. This Marvel action flick
works as a prequel, picking up right after the
airport battle in Captain America: Civil War.
After betraying Team Tony and
letting Steve Rogers escape,
Natasha is on the run, trying to lay low
and figure out her new, post-Avengers life.
But when the super spy crosses paths with
her adoptive sister, Yelena Belova, she
realizes it's time to take care of some unfinished
business. Before long, she has reunited with her
old adoptive family to take down some villains
and blow some stuff up. You know, the usual.
More than anything, though, Black
Widow is about what it means to come
from a fractured family — and it's also
a surprisingly thoughtful look at guilt,
as Natasha is still struggling to wipe all
that red from her ledger. In addition to
those engaging themes and some impressive action
scenes, Johansson gives a fantastic performance,
bolstered by a hilariously goofy David
Harbour and a charmingly snarky Pugh.
It's a sad farewell to Natasha herself, but
at least Marvel has sent her off in style.
Let's be honest — the original
Suicide Squad wasn't great.
"So that's it, we're some kind of suicide squad?"
It has a lousy 26% critical score over on
Rotten Tomatoes, and even the audience score
is a lackluster 59% — the lowest in the DCEU
so far. So why is the sequel any different?
In a sentence: it's all down to the magic of
James Gunn. The director who made everyone
fall in love with a talking raccoon and a
dancing tree was the perfect guy to shepherd
this ragtag band of antiheroes to success.
And sure enough, with The Suicide Squad,
Gunn injects the DC universe with a
heavy dose of quippy, crazy, gory fun.
Of course, Gunn hasn't totally forgotten about
the original film, as he's brought over some of
the best characters from the first installment —
but he also brings in a whole new rogues' gallery,
none of whom are guaranteed to make
it even to the movie's halfway point.
As for the plot, the titular squad is sent down to
a South American island to stop a nefarious scheme
called "Project Starfish." And yes, that's exactly
what it sounds like. By the time it's all said and
done, Gunn has offered up a Dirty Dozen-style
war movie with plenty of gags, plenty of guts,
and a near-perfect Rotten Tomatoes score.
The only lingering question… When's Part 3?
When you think about legendary action stars,
there are any number of names that might jump
to mind. But what about Karen Gillan? She's
Nebula in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
Ruby Roundhouse in the Jumanji franchise, and
famously cut her teeth in the world of Doctor
Who. But with Gunpowder Milkshake, Gillan
truly proves her action star bona fides.
This action thriller finds Gillan playing Sam,
an assassin working for a mysterious organization
called the Firm. But when a dangerous
mission goes south, Sam decides to
turn on the Firm and protect an 8-year-old
girl, drawing the wrath of her employers.
If you love the worldbuilding
of the John Wick franchise,
then Gunpowder Milkshake will be right up
your alley. It also features some of the
craziest action scenes you'll see all year,
and shines a spotlight on the ladies, too,
with women supporting women as they batter down
bad guys and mow down hit-men. Filled to the brim
with neon visuals and madcap violence, Gunpowder
Milkshake is a genuine treat for the senses.
It's a tale as old as time... or at least as
old as 1993. Somebody finds themselves trapped
in the same day, and no matter what happens, they
wake right back up on the very same morning and
repeat the same 24 hours all over again.
Groundhog Day properly kicked off the time
loop genre, but a number of movies have
played with the concept over the years.
None, though, were quite so
action-packed as Boss Level.
Starring the world's most underrated action star,
Frank Grillo, Boss Level finds Roy Pulver stuck
in a particularly painful time loop. Every
day, he gets killed. No matter what he does,
he wakes up and then, at some point or another,
he wounds up dead. Naturally, this doesn't
sit well with Mr. Pulver, and he sets out to
crack some skulls, evade his imminent death,
and figure out how he got trapped in this crazy
day. With some solid direction by Joe Carnahan
and a great villainous turn from Mel Gibson,
Boss Level is a fun spin on a familiar premise.
Who are the greatest actor-director
combos of all time? Well,
you've got Akira Kurosawa and
Toshiro Mifune , of course,
and John Ford and John Wayne. Or maybe you'd say
Martin Scorsese and Robert De Niro. And sure,
they're all great. But Toshiro Mifune never
had a gunfight with Post Malone, did he?
Enter Guy Ritchie and Jason
Statham. From Snatch to Lock,
Stock, these two action icons
have made some of the craziest,
most intense movies of all time. And, in
2021, they treated us to Wrath of Man.
The movie stars Statham as Patrick Hill,
a security guard who keeps crooks from
knocking off armored trucks. He's the new guy
on the job, but he's surprisingly good at it...
a little too good, in fact. Naturally, Hill's
co-workers begin to suspect there's more to
this rookie than meets the eye, and soon enough,
it's revealed that something sinister is going on.
Forget the plot, though — Wrath of Man is, most
importantly, filled with gunfire and explosions,
and features Statham at his action star best
here. And sometimes that's all you need.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.